foreign
well let's start with an easy question
how many of you are wearing a Fitbit or
an Apple Watch or some other kind of
Health tracking device and how many of
you have got a smartphone with you here
today
maybe I should say how many of you have
not the fact the fact that so many of us
have these technological marbles in our
pockets or on our body uh it's a short
sign of the Revolution that's taken
place in Computing over the last decade
and I want you to think with me for a
second about the elements of that
Revolution so first off other data these
devices are collecting data about our
health our movements our habits and more
and what's really important is that
those data are not generic population
data but they're data that are
personalized to us each as an individual
second and just as important are the
models inside these devices are very
powerful mathematical and statistical
models some of these models are learned
entirely from data perhaps a machine
learning model that is learned to
classify whether I'm running or walking
or biking or sleeping some of these
models are based in physics such as a
physiological model that describes the
equations that that represent cardiac
function or circadian rhythm
and now when where things get really
interesting is when we start to put the
data and the models together
mathematically this is known as data
assimilation so we have data and we have
models with data assimilation we start
updating the models as new data are
collected from the system and we don't
do this update just once but we do it
continually so as the system changes as
I get older and my circadian rhythm or
as my cardiac function is not what it
once was the new data is collected and
the models are evolving and following
along with me
now that data assimilation is really
important because it's what personalizes
the models to me
and that then gets us to the fourth
element which is the element of
prediction now that I have these
personalized models it's so powerful
because I can now get predictions or
recommendations that are tailored to me
as an individual and that are tailored
to my dynamically evolving State over my
life
so that's that's what I'm describing
this uh working together of data data
and models is likely very familiar to
all of you because it's been driving
your personal choices in retail and
entertainment and wellness for many
years
but what you might not know is that a
similar revolution has been taken place
in Engineering Systems and in
Engineering Systems the story is much
the same we have data and we have
increasing amounts of data as sensors
have become smaller lighter cheaper and
more powerful
in engineering we also have models our
models are usually grounded in physics
these models represent the governing
laws of nature they're powerful models
that let us predict how an engineering
system will respond
what you see up here on this slide is a
picture of the unmanned aircraft that I
have in my research group that we use
for a great deal of our research and for
this aircraft we have powerful finite
element models that let us predict how
the aircraft structure will respond
under different conditions so these
models let us answer questions like will
the structure of the aircraft hold
together on takeoff if I design it in
this way or what happens if the aircraft
Wing gets damaged and I continue to fly
it aggressively will the aircraft hold
together
and again just like the Fitbit and the
smartphone example we can put the data
and the models together to build a
personalized model of the engineering
system a personalized model of the
aircraft and we call this personalized
model a digital twin
so what is a digital twin it is a
personalized dynamically evolving model
of a physical system and I want you to
think about the digital twin of of my
aircraft so as I create that digital
twin I'm going to be collecting data
from the sensors onboard the aircraft
I'm going to be collecting data from
inspections I might make of the aircraft
and I'm going to be assimilating that
data into the models and what's really
important is that I'm not building a
generic model of just any old telemaster
aircraft I am building a personalized
model of the very aircraft that is right
now sitting in my garage down the road
in South Austin
and so that digital twin will capture
the differences the variability from my
aircraft to say my neighbor's aircraft
and what's more that digital twin will
not be static it's going to change as my
aircraft ages and degrades and gets
damaged and gets repaired we will be
assimilating data all the time and the
digital twin will follow the aircraft
through its life
so this is incredibly powerful I want
you to imagine now that you're an
airline or maybe in a few years time
you're an operator of a fleet of
unmanned cargo delivery drones and
imagine that you would have a digital
twin like this for every vehicle in your
Fleet and think about what that would
mean for your decision making you could
make decisions about when to maintain
any one aircraft depending on the
particular evolving state of that
aircraft you could make decisions about
how to optimally fly an aircraft on any
given day given the health of the
aircraft given the mission needs given
the environmental conditions it would
really let you optimally manage that
Fleet of aircraft
so uh this this idea of a digital twin
is pretty neat the term digital twin was
coined in 2010 in a NASA report but the
idea this idea of a personalized model
combining models and data uh go is much
older and many people point to the
Apollo program as being one of the
places where digital Twins were first
put into practice
so in the Apollo program back in the 60s
and the 70s NASA would launch a polished
spacecraft and up into space and they
would also deploy a simulator a virtual
model on the ground in Houston
to follow along on the mission and now
this became very important and it became
very useful in the Apollo 13 mission and
again perhaps you all know the story
because we've seen the movie in the
Apollo 13 mission the spacecraft
suffered a malfunction it was very badly
damaged it became stranded up in space
and so the story goes that NASA were
able to take the data from the real
aircraft the physical twin stuck up in
space feed it into the simulator into
the the virtual models on the ground in
Houston do the data assimilation
dynamically evolve the simulator so now
that it represented the conditions of
the damaged spacecraft and then used
that simulator to run predictions and
ultimately guide the decisions that
brought the astronauts back home safely
so more than 50 years later this idea
now has a really great name the name of
digital Twins and what's really exciting
is that it's moving well beyond just
aerospace engineering
so in our engineered World we're
starting to see digital twins of bridges
and other civil infrastructure for
structural Health monitoring and
predictive maintenance we're starting to
see digital twins of buildings for
Energy Efficiency digital twins of wind
farms to increase efficiency and to
reduce downtime
in the natural world there's a lot of
interest in creating digital twins of
forests Farms Ice Sheets coastal regions
oil reservoirs and even talk of trying
to create a digital twin of planet Earth
and in the medical world there's a great
deal of interest in creating digital
twins to help guide medical assessment
diagnosis personalized treatment and in
silicone drug testing
so many many exciting potential
applications of of digital twins but now
I would not like you to leave my talk
today thinking that all of this is a
reality that we can create digital twins
today of all those complex systems
it's still Beyond reach to create a
digital twin of an entire aircraft
digital twin of a cancer patient or of
planet Earth
creating digital twins of these very
very complex systems is very very
challenging and let's think for a minute
why it's so challenging so one reason
it's it's very difficult is because of
the scales that these systems cause if
you think about my aircraft
damage at the microscopic level on the
material on the wing of the aircraft
translates across scale to impact the
way the vehicle flies at the vehicle
level
in medicine we all know that again
changes at the very fine level at the at
the molecular or the cellular level in
our bodies translate across scales to
have impacts on us at the system level
at the human level
and computational models that resolve
all of these scales from the micro scale
all the way up to the system level are
computationally intractable we can't
solve them even with today's
supercomputing power
but then you might say okay well what
about the data you said we had a lot of
data can we not just learn digital twins
from data
so yes we live in an era of big data and
we have a lot of data often for our
systems but when it comes to these very
challenging complex systems and
Engineering in science and in medicine
the data by themselves are almost never
enough the data are almost always very
sparse in both space and in time the
data are almost always noisy and they're
indirect
as an engineer I can almost never
measure what it is I want to know if I
want to know about the health and the
structure inside my aircraft Wing I
can't just break it open and take a look
I am limited to those few sensors that
are on the surface of the wing taking
those measurements and then trying to
guess more than guess trying to infer
what's happening inside the wing the
same is true in medicine a medical
practitioner can't open somebody up to
take a look at an organ again we are
limited to sparse noisy and indirect
observations taken from the outside to
try to infer what's going on
so then you might say well we just have
to wait a few years because sensing
technology will get better and better
and better and that that's true maybe
maybe then we'll have enough data to
really be able to characterize what is
going on inside these very complex
systems but even that's not enough
because all that would tell us is what's
happening now and remember we have to do
more than that we have to be able to
predict what might happen in the future
if we take different different actions
so we're always going to need the models
so this sounds like a a huge Challenge
and indeed it is but the good news is
that we have a lot of Hope for
addressing this Challenge and a big part
of this hope rests on this notion of
predictive physics-based models these
are the models that encode the governing
laws of nature that let us make
predictions predict how a cancer tumor
might grow or how a cancer tumor might
respond to radiotherapy treatment or
predict how an Antarctic ice sheet might
flow under different future temperature
scenarios
and bringing these predictive
physics-based models together with
powerful machine learning with scalable
methods in data simulation and
optimization and decision making and
with high performance Computing that's
the realm of the interdisciplinary field
of computational science and that's the
focus of the Odin Institute here at UT
Austin where we bring together faculty
from 24 different departments across
campus to tackle these kinds of
challenging problems
so I'm going to close by provoking your
imagination and I hope you're excited
like I am about the idea of a digital
twin and maybe as you go home you can
look around and think oh what if we had
a digital twin of that but let's look at
some examples of some of the really
exciting areas where digital twins could
make a difference in tackling some of
the biggest problems facing society and
as I go through this you'll also see
some of the really exciting research
that we have going on here at UT Austin
so the first area is Space Systems you
probably all know we are at the dawn of
a new space era it is so exciting and
it's so exciting for our students and
what's even more exciting is that
Central Texas is right in the midst of
that new era
so uh digital twins clearly have a role
to play in managing the health and
operations of Space Systems of launch
vehicles of satellites you can see here
this is some of the work that I'm doing
together with my colleagues from the
Cockerel School uh Renato Zanetti and
shinivas better
digital twins also have a big role to
play in tracking and managing space
objects and space debris and here at UT
Austin we have one of the world's
leading experts in this area that's
Murray Baja
mariba is building uh digital twins for
space domain awareness
if we think about the environment in
geosciences again digital twins could
place such a role here this picture you
see Omar guitars's high resolution
physics-based model of the Antarctic ice
sheet which is put together with
observational data of all different
kinds to understand what might be going
on to help guide decisions about where
to to drill ice cores where to take
observations and ultimately to inform
the decision making around our our
future climate
we see also here the work of Clint
Dawson in building a digital twin of a
coastal area here the the the uh Gulf
Coast
uh again combining powerful physics
models with all the different kinds of
data and here focused on making storm
surge modeling for hurricanes even more
accurate again in support of critical
decision making
and then in medicine I think it's pretty
clear that digital twins have such a
role to play in realizing the promise of
personalized medicine here we see some
of the work of Michael Sachs from our
Odin Institute Willison Center and
moving towards patient-specific
personalized Heart Care
and the work of Tom yankalav and David
hormouse also in the uh the Odin
Institute also we're with working with
Dell medical school and part of
biomedical engineering in building uh
digital twins for cancer patients
so I hope that helps
to as I said provoke your imaginations
to think about what might be possible I
personally could be could not be more
excited about a future world where
digital twins are enabling safer more
efficient Engineering Systems they're
enabling a better understanding of the
natural world around us and they're
enabling better medical outcomes for all
of us as an individual thank you
[Applause]
[Music]